the property brothers just keep on
getting bigger and bigger
so Jonathan drew Scott or just with the
launch throne magazine and they're also
on the cover of this week's people mag
with the headline new loves new lies
soju is ready to start a family with
wife Linda and Jonathan is talking about
his new romance with Zooey Deschanel
that surprised a lot of people they met
you know while they were shooting
carpool karaoke together there was
chemistry right away and we just
literally make each other laugh non-stop
I have never been in a relationship
where my partner is as romantic if not
even more romantic than I am I mean
privacy is definitely an issue we have a
challenge in finding somewhere where you
know we don't have people coming to take
pictures or you know people chasing us
down so you know privacy is key but the
funniest thing is everyone's like she's
dating who like I'm good I got perks I
can fit you I can fix your plumbing I
can paint I can design a space like I
got all kinds of perks you know but
definitely I don't think it was expected
I mean we come from very different
worlds on the surface when you look at
the careers of what we do but it's
uncanny how many things we have in
common both having an equestrian
background to our education to
everything it's unbelievable how much we
have in common
he's also very tough and and my personal
spirit is very good at escape rooms he's
getting an escape route so is better an
escape room guys sorry Jonathan drew is
better in an escape room but Jonathan's
good is that appealing to Zoey listen if
they're going on if they're doing a
double date let's say they say it drew a
Linda and Jonathan's on double date and
like they're competing against each
other of a dis escape room thing I've
ever stuck in a roof you're like some
kind of situation where you're locked in
the room Jonathan I wasn't thinking like
a real-life why so you see more than if
you're on people tv.com dennis has been
playing their game do they have a game
too
oh they haven't van have a nap oh do
they
Paul says any man that can do rhinos is
such a good catch excuses 11:00 so
action to them is exactly how it
describes
but I'm like how is it like I don't
think it's not weird like I haven't met
Zoey but I've met
Jonathan truly cat-like he's a super
nice guy like he has a good job goes to
look like people's perception of
celebrity like putting them in boxes
right so if oil was dating a film actor
or a TV actor other people would be like
oh yeah I guess that makes sense right
but because you know yeah I don't get
how it's so strange to people that they
would be dating I think like it's one of
those things like the universe totally
made that happen cuz even like when I
saw they're doing carpool karaoke
together I thought why are they like the
Scott brothers doing carpool karaoke
with the Deschanel combination then this
happens it was like I guess one of those
things where the universe made that
happy that was really just an elaborate
sort of like Gordon completing credit
for that or the producers that did that
michael says privacy is key does he
believe it well I mean yeah at a certain
point you're trying to date a thing it
must be still weird when you're two
celebrities trying to go on like yeah a
date and just get to know each other and
yeah you have to deal with this whole
that factor like you're at a restaurant
like obviously everyone knows easily
like Jonathan said that they are an
interesting couple right like that their
particular dating story is interesting
to people so it would be kind of hard I
imagine yeah commences just went up a
little bit let me just see we look at
their show regularly and find them very
interesting and find them a great
communicators Louie says I want to date
them yes I'm happy for them both the
hypothesis that makes them more real
scooby says Zoey would be better suited
with the musician what does a someone's
profession have to do it I mean other
than the fact that he can fix stuff but
they're both in the world yeah the book
linearity world so it works